my research looks at epigenetics and how
the genome is expressed in different
cell types and no one would have ever
thought ten years ago that's what an
engineer would be doing this if that's
the realm of cell biology what we're
using fundamental engineering principles
to really look at changes in the cell
expression the genome is a big deal
right now understanding what genes are
there but not just what genes are there
how are they expressed and how are they
expressed such that my ears state ears
and my liver stays a liver the whole way
through my body's development it's
really important so we look at this as
DNA is both a very complex polymer
system so we can apply traditional
aspects of chemical engineering but also
it's a complex polymer that does
important things so we really combine
these two techniques and we're able to
get at very fundamental important cell
biological problems that like I said
could not be dealt with any other way
tissue engineering and drug delivery are
the next big things for most engineers
but unfortunately they haven't been
successful because people don't really
understand the fundamental character of
the cell and that's what we're trying to
do from the smallest molecular level
inside the cell trying to understand
what controls it now we have a building
on the shoulders of giants in biology so
biologists have done a great job of
explaining what binds to what what
interacts with what the time scales and
things like that we're really looking at
the whole system now and understanding
how that system is all put together and
what could possibly be the regulatory
components of the system things like
that so I think the future is unlimited
once you understand something you can
change it so we're also looking at the
changes involved in cancer metastasis so
once we understand what's really the
underlying mechanism that would turn to
normally possibly over proliferated cell
into a tumor we can control it so I
firmly believe that understanding comes
before creation and design in particular
in biology we're making big headway now
into understanding so the future can
really work on the design concepts of
making biology better
you